das ging bei ist bei uns
spd-generalsekretär toller tag für euch
bei der spd natürlich wir haben vorhin
armin laschet gehört und ich möchte
ihnen einen kurzen satz vorlesen sehen
er gesagt hat und zwar hat gesagt keine
partei kann aus diesen klaren ergebnis
einen regierungsauftrag ableiten auch
nicht die spd wollte natürlich sagen
kann aus diesem ergebnis einen klaren
regierungsauftrag
ableiten und hat sich da selbst bloß
gestellt auch nicht die spd
ja ich weiß gar nicht wie man das noch
kommentieren soll aber armin laschet
schafft ist ja sogar sich am wahltag zu
blamieren wenn er die stimme abgibt und
alles was wir jetzt gerade erleben zeigt
ja dass da ein spitzenkandidat ein
kanzlerkandidat außer rand und band ist
dass das er jetzt einfach versucht seine
macht zu retten und das die union ihm
ziemlich egal ist bei mir im wahlkreis
an der basis mit wo alle jetzt eine
ehrliche aufarbeitung dieses ergebnisses
fordern aber überhaupt nicht damit
einverstanden sind dass armin laschet
jetzt der meinung ist er könnte um die
kanzler werden und da muss man ja
wirklich sagen das ergebnis gestern war
eindeutig die spd hat sich von platz
drei auf platz 1 gekämpft wenn ich die
persönlichen vergleiche zwischen laschet
und schaut sie die sind auch eindeutig
wir sind die stärkste partei wir haben
gestern haben gewonnen und wir wollen
jetzt gucken dass wir schnell eine
regierung mit fdp und grünen auf den weg
bringen
1 wirklich gerne wissen er hat ja
öffentlich nie wie sich an die unter
demokraten gehört zum wahlsieg
gratuliert hat er olaf scholz mal eine
sms geschickt oder sowas und also nach
meinen informationen hat das nicht getan
das ist etwas was sich so auch in der
tat wie sie sagen das ich kenne ich so
dass man sich gratuliert also derjenige
der vorne ist dem sagt man mal gut
gemacht herzlichen glückwunsch das ist
nicht passiert und das ist eigentlich
der anstand den ich unter demokraten
auch erwartet dass man gratuliert wir
haben jetzt den ganzen vormittag hier
den bundesvorstand der cdu verfolgt mit
dem auf was dort gesprochen wurde da gab
es mehrere sätze in richtung olaf scholz
um einen olaf scholz ist nicht der könig
also die anspielung darauf dass olaf
scholz am ende auch nicht kanzler werden
könnten was passiert da gerade bei der
union also erstmal finde ich sehr
spannend dass man wieder jeden satz
nachlesen kann der dort im präsidium und
parteivorstand gesprochen wird wir
hatten auch beide gremien heute das war
wir wussten auch ein bisschen was von
der es ja aber da sind diese zitate
nicht also das ist ja vielleicht auch
ein signal an fdp und grüne also wie
will man mit den verhandlungen führen
vertrauensvoll wenn alles sofort ja nein
bild durch gestochen wird also das
erschüttert ja glaube ich schon das
vertrauen ich verstehe natürlich dass
das hier freut aber man hat ja bei
jamaika damals gesehen wie man
verhandlungen katastrophe führen kann
und die union ist in einem
katastrophalen zustand aber das was doch
gerade passiert ist das in frage
gestellt wird dass olaf scholz der
gewinner des gestrigen abends ist mit
der spd sind und noch mal das ist ein
deutliches ergebnis wir liegen deutlich
vorne es ist normal bisher in den wahlen
immer gewesen dass die partei die als
sieger vom platz geht dass die dann auch
die gespräche führt und deswegen haben
wir heute im präsidium und
parteivorstand gesagt wir werden jetzt
gespräche führen mit den grünen mit der
fdp was sagen die in alles einmischen
gekommen laschet hat gesagt er hat schon
mit christian lindner telefoniert das
schon alles klar haben wir haben ja auch
in nrw koaliert und heute will er
anderen in bernburg anrufen was machen
sie denn wenn christian lindner und die
grünen sagen ja amila cellist war zwei
tage machen sie war mit dem das werden
die nicht tun also da bin ich mir ganz
sicher dass die grünen und die grünen
und die fdp wissen dass wir jetzt mit
der spd im gespräch führen werden dass
man auslotet an welchen stellen passt es
zusammen wo sind vielleicht differenzen
aber es geht noch eine große
verantwortung die man gemeinsam hat
jetzt eine stabile regierung zu bilden
die großen zukunftsaufgaben anzupacken
und ganz ehrlich ich meine armin laschet
traut sich nicht mal nach dem
fraktionsvorsitz zugreifen also
eigentlich wäre es doch jetzt an ihm zu
sagen er will jetzt der starke mann in
der union sein vorsitzender der cdu aber
jetzt auch zu sagen wenn er nicht mehr
ministerpräsident in nordrhein westfalen
ist doch der automatische schritt dass
man nach dem fraktionsvorsitz greift
aber nicht mal die kraft hat er gerade
und gott der unterwelt
ob fdp und grüne sich nicht in diesen
tagen noch mal fragen mit wem redet man
eigentlich an der union wer hat
eigentlich das sagen wer bestimmt
eigentlich den kurs aber da sind wir
noch mehr unterstützung alle im
bundesvorstand heute haben gesagt ja wir
wollen jamaika-regierung ist besser wir
wollen nicht in die opposition ist ja
nicht so dass die cdu jetzt angefangen
hätte armin laschet irgendwie zum
beispiel
lese ich auch zwischentöne also ich lese
ja auch die die sagen regieren ist jetzt
nicht das wichtigste wir müssen erstmal
das ergebnis aufarbeiten es gibt
kritiker nahmen laschet ich habe
kretschmer gelesen der auch sehr
deutlich dass in frage stellt also da
gibt es schon unterschiedliche töne und
jetzt warten wir mal ab wie denn auch
die fraktionsgremien der union laufen
die haben einiges aufzuarbeiten also der
balken ging bis tief in den keller das
ist ein historisch schlechtes
wahlergebnis das die union da
eingefahren hat und anscheinend tut
armin laschet so als ob nichts passiert
wäre dann nicht sogar das was ihm
schaden wirklich mal wenn wir mal nicht
mehr über armin laschet sondern über sie
das kanzleramt haben sie ja auch noch
nicht sicher und da armin laschet sich
offen an bietet natürlich für die
jamaika koalition haben die fdp und die
grünen natürlich ein pfund in der
hinterhand wenn es jetzt in die
verhandlungen geht um eine
ampelkoalition und werden ihnen einiges
abverlangen können
spitzensteuersatz und so weiter und so
fort wo sind da rote linien oder geht es
ihnen auch nur um die idee das ist das
was robert habeck er sagt wir müssen
eine neue idee für deutschland haben und
ansonsten pragmatisch sein das ist schon
historische phase gerade merkel dort auf
nach 16 jahren das gibt jetzt große
zukunftsaufgabe eine künftige regierung
anpacken muss und das geht jetzt
überhaupt nicht darum öffentlich
irgendwelche roten linien zu ziehen oder
zu sagen das sind die grenzen über die
wir nicht rübergehen wir müssen jetzt
ausloten ob grüne und fdp sagen ja wir
sind bereit gemeinsam verantwortung zu
übernehmen staatsmodernisierung das
thema europa digitalisierung auch die
große frage des klimaschutzes sind wir
drei parteien bereit ihr zu sagen es
muss richtig angepackt werden und wir
müssen jetzt substanziell in den
nächsten vier jahren vorankommen und
dann muss das eine regierung sein die
zum beispiel anders geprägt ist als die
schwarz gelbe regierung 2009 wo ja vom
ersten tag an man sich die butter auf
dem brot nicht gegönnt hat wo die fdp am
ende der legislatur rausgeflogen ist aus
dem fall weil man so hart gegeneinander
gegangen ist und deswegen geht es auch
um 9 einen neuen stil des regierens es
geht um ein neues
verhandelt das heute deutlich gemacht er
hat gesagt es muss jetzt ein stil sein
bei dem alle drei auch ganz klar
deutlich machen wir können uns auch
vorstellen dass wir in der konstellation
wieder gewählt genau und vor allem der
fdp werden natürlich auch entgegenkommen
müssen robert habeck hat das wohin
gesagt hat gesagt die partei die das
lager wechseln muss also die fdp hat die
größere zumutung zu tragen und eine
ampel kann nicht rot grün sein und ein
bisschen gelber kit um dann am ende eine
mehrheit zu bekommen vor allem der fdp
werden sie also entgegenkommen müssen
und da gibt es natürlich die größten
unterschiede aber es gibt auch viele
gemeinsamkeiten nochmal digitalisierung
staatsmodernisierung der
gesellschaftlichen aufbruch der in
diesem land jetzt wieder stattfinden
kann den juni an vielen stellen
blockiert hat das sind alles dinge wo
ich sage lasst uns erstmal über
gemeinsamkeiten reden lassen uns davon
reden wie die gesellschaft aussehen soll
in die wir in die wir wollen und was wir
für große ziele haben und dann haben sie
recht denn wenn man die programme
nebeneinander legt da gibt es
unterschiede da gibt es sachen wo wir
uns sicherlich hart streiten werden noch
in verhandlungen aber das werden wir
intern und nicht öffentlich jetzt gab es
mehrere angriffe heute im bundesvorstand
gegen olaf scholz und thomas strobl hat
gesagt oder shirts ist kein
kassenschlager was ihre antwort er ist
der kanzlerkandidat der houston
beliebtheitswerte hat der mit seiner
partei das beste ergebnis eingefahren
hat und ich glaube viele in der union
wir hätten lieber einen anderen gehabt
zu haben laschet dann der vorwurf ist
kein ost verstehe das hat armin laschet
auch gesagt also olaf scholz hat gestern
in ostdeutschland ein wahlkreis direkt
gewonnen und wenn man auf die landkarte
guckt dann sieht man die spd hat in
mecklenburg vorpommern in brandenburg in
thüringen sachsen anhalt viele
wahlkreise gewonnen und das haben wir
getan auch durch einen kanzlerkandidaten
olaf show und was soll uns das sagen
dass amila stattfindet noch mal die
frage dass olaf scholz kein könig ist
was ist olaf scholz für sie ich will gar
nicht dass er könig ist ich will das ja
gewählt da kannst du dieses landes ist
wir sind in der demokratischen wahl
angetreten ist ist ja die union die die
letzten wochen immer so ein bisschen
getan hat ihn alles gehört also diese
dieser vorwurf auf der erbschleicherei
also das zeigt das verständnis der union
die gehören die denken denen gehört das
land aber sowas wie könig kommt uns gar
nicht über die lippen wir wollen dass
olaf scholz der nächste kanzler ist und
das sind alles verzweifelte attacken von
einem armin laschet der gerade um sein
überleben um sein politisches überleben
kämpft das kann ich nachvollziehen aber
das ist nicht seriös und ich bin
gespannt wie lange die union das mit
macht man muss auch zeigen dass man lust
hat zu regieren
das alles freudlos ist hat er vorhin
auch gesagt in der präsident ich glaube
wer olaf scholz in diesen tagen erlebt
der sieht der hat lust der hat große
lust die veränderung in diesem land
voranzubringen aber es geht um
seriosität es geht darum ist jetzt auch
ernsthaft zu machen und normal armin
laschet ist ein bisschen außer rand und
band wie olaf scholz in diesen tagen
erlebt er sieht der ist vorbereitet der
weiß welche großen aufgaben vorliegen
und die partei steht hinter ihm hier
klicken viele stöhnen natürlich auch oh
gott so viele gespräche ist es alles so
komplex man kommt nicht auf einen nenner
wie lange glauben sie realistisch
gesehen wird es dauern bis eine
regierung zustande kommt also jetzt war
gestern die wahl jetzt haben alle mal
ein bisschen gefeiert bei uns zumindest
in der partei wir haben uns heute in den
gremien gesagt dass sie jetzt schnell
sein dass man zusammen kommt ein
schnelles gespräch mit den grünen ein
schnelles gespräch mit der fdp dann
werden wir das bewerten und das muss
jetzt in den nächsten tagen stattfinden
dh bis weihnachten dass wir nicht warten
bis weihnachten muss man sowieso nicht
warten mit den gesprächen aber selbst
wenn es dann darum geht und das hoffe
ich mal dass wir eine gemeinsame
regierung bilden dann wollen wir das
schnell tun erwarten sie dass die
kanzlerin noch eine ansprache halten
wird eine weihnachtsansprache oder wie
mein ansporn ist dass wir schneller sind
als dass die kanzlerin noch arbeiten
muss weihnachten das klingt bei vielen
dank für den besuch ihres studiums sehr
gern dankeschön danke
[Musik]